in einem land vor unserer zeit vielen
vielen millionen jahren lange noch bevor
der mensch das rad erfand bevor er das
elektrische licht entdeckte von autos
über die welt touren millionen jahre vor
diesen menschlichen errungenschaften gab
es ein bild über die youtuber hieß es
und er verbrachte seine zeit damit
wochen gar monatelang nur minecraft jump
league auf seinem kanal hochzuladen
inzwischen bei so viel zeit vergangen
dass die menschen vergast was minecraft
schafik war dass es bei einzelnen sehr
ordentliche spielen
doch er ist zurück ohne scheiß leute
holy shit willkommen zu einer neuen
runde minecraft jan blick jetzt fragt
ihr euch wahrscheinlich wie sowie dieser
[ __ ] wieder bei kräften blick auf
seinem kanal hoch mit dem er jetzt drei
monate lang an minecraft gemacht hat
folgendermaßen leute ich habe dieses
jahr auf dem video days von einigen
leuten gehört wo geld endlich mal
kräftig letzte nochmal john peacock
das hat mich ein bisschen zum nachdenken
gebracht dort habe ich mich gefragt
wieso fragen mich die leute ausgerechnet
an minecraft jump
die leute fragen nicht nach der hacker
obwohl doch einige hacker schon fragen
aber meistens in den kommentaren
übrigens auf die hacker schaut momentan
gar nicht mehr so viel bock ich gesagt
deswegen kommt ihr auch nicht mehr so
oder so mich haben extrem viele nach
minecraft jump gefragt wie gesagt ich
komme jetzt nachdenken so ok bauteil
möchte viele leute nach gesamten
ausgerechnet jump it's okay ich hab zwar
langsam gespielt aber was hat es damit
auf sich dass so viele leute danach
fragen habe ich gefragt warum würdest
euch das mal wieder mal kräftig
hochladen und erhalten die ganzen leute
jahr
camping ist schwierig da kann ich über
das video an machen kann wenn die
wegschmeißen und einfach im hintergrund
das video durchlaufen lassen wenn ich
etwas anderes mache keine ahnung
hausaufgaben mache ich dachte wenn im
moment so ok krass es gibt zwar recht
doch noch einige leute die nicht
vergessen haben dass ich auch mal mit
hoch geladen habe auf meinem youtube
kanal und deswegen heute voll mit diesem
video loslegen die große umfrage seit so
gut und schreibt jetzt mit in die
kommentare auch wenn es normalerweise
nicht eure ding ist auf diesen kommentar
antworten sachen auszuschreiben bleibt
bitte jetzt mal die kommentare was ihr
davon haltet wenn ich mein kreft
hochlage ist es was für euch oder würde
er sein sohn er ist überhaupt nicht mein
ding weil ich momentan extrem unsicher
bin ob auf meinem kanal überhaupt noch
minecraft laufen sollte ob sie überhaupt
noch leute gibt die mannschaft
interessiert oder vielleicht etwas
anders schon bei mir was anderes sehen
wollen sind auch irgendwelche zuschauer
draußen oder ist die mehrzahl der leute
jetzt auf anderen konten eingestellten
das ist wie gewohnt wenn ich mir an den
kopf hauen
seit so guten schreibt gerade in den
kommentaren da können wir eine kleine
abstimmung machen und dementsprechend
kann ich auch meinen content anpassen
weil ich momentan wieder ein bisschen
lust habt minecraft zu spielen
irgendwann hat mich nämlich auch dass er
möchte was für die meisten in minecraft
youtube erwischt nämlich der moment wo
man sie einfach denkt okay ich kein bock
auf dieses spiel bei west bei mir nicht
so krass war aber ich hatte halt
irgendwann auch keine lust mir dass ich
mich jedes mal wenn ich hier machen
möchte einfach irgendwie hinsetzen
musste um minecraft spielen muss ich
hatte man zwar viel übung und kann so
ein bisschen voran aber es hieß hat auch
jedes mal wenn du wie du machen willst
musst du dich an einem pc setzen und
mussten minecraft spielt weil dieses
musst du bist dann beim kopf drin war
ich hab mir erklärt dass ich das machen
muss und da hatte ich irgendwann gar
keine lust mehr drauf
das wollte man versucht ist ich hab' ich
hab's wirklich ich habe es versucht ich
weiß ich bin nicht so gut ich habe drei
monate lang an minecraft gespielt kommt
einfach so eine pappnase ein finish
einfach wenn ich bei 50 prozent betonen
dreck sieg mit einer eher leute wie
gesagt die ganze sache ist doch kein
statement wir probieren es einfach mal
aus und ich schaue die ganz genau auf
eure resonanzen auf eure likes des video
video geht noch halbwegs die frage ist
wie gesagt nicht ob jetzt in minecraft
ein schöner werde sondern die frage ist
ob ich gelegentlich dann waren aber
minecraft mache wenn ich irgendwo
lustige idee hat folgende minecraft
folge wenn ja schreibt das unbedingt in
die kommentare wie schon gesagt und
20.000 mal ja ihr dürft jetzt
aufschreiben
doch dort von 40 mal gesagt dürfte
schreiben ihr wollt
euro
nein nein nein gesperrt hier ist
gesperrt ich gesagt ja oh mein gott
ob das reicht den weg zu lacken ya basta
mich holt wo mein gott mit diesem großen
equipment
ich persönlich hätte vom gefühl her
jetzt gesagt dass die leute die gar
keinen bock mehr als die leute seid ihr
dass ihr mir eine woche darauf habt
minecraft zuschauen bei mir reicht schon
so lange her ist nicht mehr einfach
vorstelle in meinem kopf das allemal
kosten schon weg sind
wir haben wirklich eine holzleiter soll
jetzt einfach umbringen gibt es eine
möglichkeit diesen tod wir sind tot
wir sind institute schweizer ja ich
schwitze tatsächlich man es sind 30 grad
da wo ich wohne um einen pc glüht weil
er den shader nicht verträgt ja ich bin
schweizer jetzt ja leute die stats sind
auf jeden fall so wie früher würde ich
sagen 44 prozent komplett ist schon dass
kraft das schaffen wenige jump nicht
beendet ist halt auch nicht üblich also
die meisten beenden heutzutage djs an
drei kills sind auf jeden fall auch
schon yahoo ach was das playmate service
für mich als pro gamer einstellen um den
server zu repräsentieren
ja und was alisa 10.000 euro pro monat
das zu wenig 20
geht auch okay 20.000 euro als gut leute
alles in allem alte liebe rostet nicht
minecraft skills aber schon gesagt euer
feedback gerne in die kommentare und wir
sind bereit wieder wieder in dem ich mir
entweder an den kopf hauen oder mike
spieler